not a particularly good week for
republican senator lindsey graham a
judge has ordered lindsey graham to
testify
in the georgia trump fraud case now the
back story on this is that in the state
of georgia trump wanted trump demanded
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty
votes he called brad raffensberger and
others in georgia and in the midst of
this lindsey graham also made a phone
call lindsey graham is a sort of
i guess in a sense i would call him a
fair weather trump supporter when things
are going well for trump he supports
trump but then on the night of january
60 said it's over it's time to move on
okay
he lindsey graham was subpoenaed in the
georgia
grand jury investigation of trump's
attempt to overturn to steal let's call
it what it is to steal the georgia
electoral votes lindsey graham upon
receiving the subpoena said i'm going to
fight this subpoena his lawyers used all
sorts of different arguments and a judge
has said no you've got to show up let's
take a look at this nbc news report a
judge ordered senator lindsey graham to
testify
in front of a special grand jury in
georgia investigating former president
donald trump's alleged attempts to
overturn the results of the 2020
election fulton county superior court
judge robert mcburney ordered that
graham will be required to testify
august 2nd the judge's certification
filed monday describes graham as a
necessary and material witness to the
grand jury probe the development was
reported earlier by wsb tv
graham's office did not immediately
respond to requests for comment the
senator's attorney said last week he
would not comply the grand jury also
subpoenaed members of trump's former
legal team including personal lawyer
rudy giuliani now one of the arguments
that lindsay's lawyers made in this
entire thing
is that his actions in calling georgia
officials to ask what's going on can we
get the right count whatever he was
doing
the argument his lawyers made was that
lindsay's actions are protected under
these constitutional safeguards for
members of congress not getting punished
for their speech or actions performed in
the course of their legislative duties
so to explain that in layman's terms
the lawyers for lindsay said when
lindsay called
to inquire about those election results
he was performing legislative duties as
a senator of the united states
that probably sounds like bs to you and
it is and both the d.a and the judge
said
graham isn't a georgia resident and
graham is not a georgia politician
and u.s senators
don't have any legitimate congressional
function in personally calling state
election officials to argue about the
results or to suggest that the results
might be wrong it's it doesn't make any
sense it's not an art but as a senator
he has no role there he has no standing
he's not a voter so he can't use that
argument what he was doing was he was
trying to trade on his name and
influence by calling and saying hey this
is lindsey graham i'm a u.s senator i'm
paying attention to what you're doing
don't you think maybe you could review
the results and maybe see if they
weren't right but there was no
legitimate legislative function as a us
senator being served there and
unfortunately the judge agreed with that
you don't get to choose which laws you
would like to follow
i mean sometimes these people in power
do but you shouldn't get to anyway and
lindsey graham at least for now and
we'll see if he
appeals the decision if it's subject to
appeal or what he tries to do between
now and august 2nd in principle he is
supposed to show up and testify on
august 2nd i know that clearly his
lawyers don't want him to that's why
they tried every possible argument to
get him out of it and if indeed he does
testify it should be absolutely
fascinating we will have the clips and
more of the stories that we talked about
in this segment on the david pakman show
instagram which you can find at david
pakman's show also follow me on
instagram at david.pakman
the uh the hate voicemail i posted
yesterday
incredible reaction i think close to a
thousand comments on it
listen to it on my instagram
david.pacman let me know what you make
of it
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american
old-growth forests and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from fast
growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major
impact on carbon real paper also uses no
plastic packaging so we often talk about
what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 percent off your first shipment
when you sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below